find the absolute value of X when X is
equal to 5 X is equal to negative 10 and
X is equal to negative 12 so the
absolute value it's almost the the way
of writing it is almost more complicated
than what it really is the absolute
value is really just the distance of x
from 0 distance distance from 0 so let
me just draw a fast number line over
here so if I were to first let's just
put 0 right over here since we're
thinking about the distance from 0 so
let's just think about the absolute
value let's think about the absolute
value of X when X is equal to 5 so
that's equivalent to the absolute value
of 5 we just substituted 5 for X the
absolute value of 5 is the distance of 5
from 0 so you go 1 2 3 4 5 5 is exactly
5 to the right of 0 so the absolute
value of 5 is just 5 now I think you
already you get to see this is a pretty
straightforward concept now let's do
something a little more interesting
absolute value of negative 10 when x is
or the absolute value of X when X is
equal to negative 10 so let's just put
negative 10 in for X this is the
distance that negative 10 is from 0 and
so let's just go negative 1 negative 2
negative 3 negative 4 negative 5
negative 6 negative 7 negative 8
negative 9 negative 10 I should extend
the number line more so this right here
is negative 10 so how far is it away
from 0 well it's 10 to the left of 0 so
you put a 10 here and so in general
absolute value will always be a positive
quantity and we're thinking about just
absolute values of just numbers it's
just going to be the really the positive
version of that number let's do one more
well they tell us to do one more the
absolute value of x when x is equal to
negative 12 so we have the absolute
value of negative 12 is going we don't
even have to look at the number line
it's just going to be the positive
version of negative 12 it's just going
to be equal to 12 and this is just
saying that negative 12 is 12 away from
0 and we could draw it over here this
negative 11 negative 12 is right over
here it is one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve away
from zero